wer bei schon
jeden tag ist
schon heute morgen sind wir immer und -
neubeginn
es ist wieder soweit wir haben
die wir jeden dritten donnerstag in
münchen
veranstalten und wir sehr gern musikern
hier ist unser proberaum und einen raum
weiter dann findet die party startet der
vorwärts unser zeug und dann ist eine
mächtige zidlicky partien
ich möchte euch den besten beatles ganz
münchen vorstellen später kann man
die leute lieben ihn erlebt die leute da
bleibt immer bis zum ende nach
münsterlingen und liegt geilen sound
alles mit echten platten ohne laptop
was ich ja echt ein schwierigsten findet
er darauf eingehen mit stimmung gratis
muss die mädels bei laune halten
wenn die mädels tanzen die partie also
die heute oder
sterben bedeutet freie improvisationen
auf der bühne egal ob musik oder text
bislang ist für die musiker immer das
wichtigste war da kannst du möchte ich
die leute direkt erreichen
ob er einen rapper ein schlagzeuger
einen sänger oder ein geiger ist ist
dann ziemlich egal die musik ist ja die
universelle sprache die jeder versteht
die anderen musiker sind alles bekannte
freunde und immer mehr
münchner szene bei münchen ist nicht
ganz so verbreitet
es sind schon viele neue songs
entstanden durch die session oder
generell ist aber dass halt einfach
brainstorm manchmal sachen dabei nicht
mehr ausgehalten kann sagt tate ist
offen
das fazit von 16 partien ich bin noch
ein bisschen weiter und jene zu hause